Meanwhile at the Smithsonian Museum
of American history,
which is just a bigger map,
bigger thing.
We're going to do the same thing.
One thing I'll show you here is that
here the map is a little bit bigger.
And in fact if you take
a look at this map,
it was actually created by
a robot doing what's called Slam.
Where we actually use
the robot to build the map.
So here we have again,
the robot doesn't know where it is.
It takes a bunch of measurements.
These are where the actual
measurements are.
The robot doesn't know that yet.
And this is the set of
particles that survive.
So you see it's clumped up a little but
it doesn't know.
So it moves,
takes another set of measurements, and
these are the particles that survive.
Now with just two sets of measurements.
Almost everything else
here has gone away, and
we're getting a bigger clump there.
Just two sets of those measurements.
Right?
Propagate forward, take a measurement,
and now you can see,
as it's advanced forward, it has pretty
much very little ambiguity left.
So again, just by taking these simple
measurements, it knows where it is.